[Applause]
[Music]
New Guinea looks like another planet in
fact it looks like it belongs in JRR
Tolkien's middle-earth but if this were
the case it would definitely be Mordor a
place where things like this are
happening right now in the 21st century
[Music]
missing Explorer discovered in Papua New
Guinea and I know what you're gonna say
I mean come on Simon one bad story
doesn't mean the whole island is bad and
yes well you're right about that it's
actually even worse Papua New Guinea
women and children killed in tribal
massacre and I might be wondering well
why are we talking to you about New
Guinea on visual politic what kind of
political issues can they have going on
well believe me there's a lot to talk
about here first of all New Guinea is
the third biggest island on the planet
that's after Australia and Greenland but
there is something more if you pay
attention to the map you can see the
island is divided into two halves by a
perfectly straight line this is the
border that separates Papua New Guinea a
sovereign state from Western Papua
region of Indonesia that is here in the
Indonesian part where a big separatist
movement has emerged so what would be a
state if Papua became independent from
Indonesia well right here you have one
very good reason
[Music]
Freeport's goldmine in Papua largest in
the world exactly we're talking about
gold copper and yes soiling gas remember
when I compared Papua to Mordor
well Papua even has its own Mount Doom
where you can make gold rings and
various other things
this explains why Papua nationalism is a
headache for many so today's question is
what did pop ones really want from
Indonesia do they want to be their own
country or would they rather join their
Eastern neighbours and can they get the
sovereignty that they want today we're
going to answer all of these questions
but before we do let's take a look back
at the history of this island the island
nobody cared about over the years New
Guinea was controlled by the United
Kingdom Germany and the Netherlands and
I say controls because New Guinea was
considered so worthless that nobody was
interested in turning it into a proper
colony each of these European powers
just planted a flag created a harbor so
they could control the sea route
surrounding the islands and left it
alone but nobody really cared about what
was going on on the island itself so
most of the indigenous people over New
Guinea didn't even realize they'd been
conquered or colonized by anybody so of
course they kept their tribal system the
same as they'd had it before
this also explains why nobody tried to
take control of New Guinea during the
period of decolonization
basically during the 1960s and 70s all
the European powers I left the island
and divided it in two parts the line
that divides New Guinea is the 141st
Meridian from this line to the east is
Papua New Guinea an independent
sovereign country from this line to the
west we have an Indonesian province and
you might be wondering well what were
all of those tribes doing while this was
happening so as Lu said earlier many of
them had no idea about any of these
political maneuvers most of them didn't
even see European people in their day to
day lives
for example the Doni is one of the
biggest pop one ethnicities they've been
living in a bit of a stone-age existence
until 1938 when a plane flew over the
great Donnie Valley this is the first
contact that this tribe had with people
from outside the tribe this is far from
a tiny minority group Doni tribes are
estimated to have more than 200,000
people and they represent about 5% of
the Indonesian pop one population
technically they're Indonesian but many
of them are not even aware of this and
you might think that by now 2019 things
would have changed civilization and
internet connections everywhere right
well actually no just look at this news
story
[Music]
this remote tribe in New Guinea cuts
boys skin with razors so they look like
crocodiles and yes I said tribes in
plural because on this islands there are
more than 1,000 tribes and perhaps there
are many more that we don't even know
about and you might now be saying why
did Indonesia take the western part and
the answer is that Indonesia was
formerly a Dutch colony so that when
they got their independence they claims
this Dutch controlled territory too
since none of the tribes protested it
was given to the brand's new Indonesian
state and Indonesian quickly learns to
care about this worth of a silent
basically since the moments of heart a
the Indonesian dictator and father of
the nations set foot on the islands he
realized there was a lot more there than
just tribal people today one-third of
the gas that Indonesia exports is
produced in Papua and then we have the
grass Berg mine
Wow every day
Freeport produces 240 kilograms of gold
from Papua but wait a minute because it
doesn't in there this grass Peck mine is
not only the world's largest gold mine
it's also the second largest when it
comes to copper
yes dear viewers Papua gives a lot in
exchange for not very much from the
Indonesians and this explains why
Indonesia is not willing to let them go
in fact the current Indonesian president
Joko Widodo is going in the opposite
direction yeah until recently the grass
berg mine was owned by a private company
and indonesia has just nationalized it
[Music]
kinesia rests control of three ports
grass bird mine ending long battle but
make no mistake indonesian interest for
Papua New Guinea ends with the islands
resources Parwan citizens are considered
second-class citizens and the
Indonesians look at them as inferior
racism is so blatant that they usually
just called the monkeys and yes to most
of the pop ones this is an insult
[Music]
monkey slur into revolution these days
with the government led by Joko Widodo
things are changing the Indonesian
government is starting to build some
highways and passing some laws that are
more friendly to the indigenous people
but none of this is enough for the pop
one nationalists that now you might be
wondering well sort of the Indonesian
pop ones really want to they want to
join their Eastern neighbours well let's
take a look
[Music]
papa and even worse papa
life is hard in indonesian papua but it
is heaven compared with life in
independent papua basically if you get
caught by a tribe there you could in
fact be their dinner and I'm not
exaggerating kidnapped by cannibals and
tortured on dream holiday to Papua New
Guinea but wait a minute because the
cities are not much better Port Moresby
the capital is considered the world's
most dangerous city it is controlled by
the rascal the look of street gangs
their hobbies include alcohol drugs and
killing and I know what you're thinking
I mean come on Simon there are lots of
dangerous cities in the world you sure
that Port Moresby is that exceptional
well actually yes look at what happens
during the APEC summit the APEC summit
is the asia-pacific Economic Cooperation
forum in 2018 they wanted to hold a
meeting here and well this is what
happens Papua New Guinea hosts APEC CEO
summit on cruise ship yep no matter how
many security companies and bodyguards
they hired politicians said they would
not set foot on lands there so the whole
event had to be held on a cruise ship
docked next to the coast extreme poverty
rates in Papua New Guinea are as high as
40 percent in comparison the rate in
neighboring Indonesia and Papua is 25
percent elsewhere in Indonesia drops to
about 6 percent of course we should take
all of these statistics with a pinch of
salt because as you can imagine there
are many areas on this island where
nobody can collect any reliable data
anyway Indonesian pop ones dude once
their gas oil and gold to be stolen by
Indonesians but they also don't want
them to be stolen by their Eastern
neighbors either basically they just
wanna for themselves Benny Wenda is a
separatist leader who lives in exile in
London his goal is to rule what he hopes
to name Western Papua but the question
is could this territory really become
independence you see the Western pop
world liberation movements led by Benny
Wenda has collected 1.8 million
signatures to request the United Nations
hold a referendum so now let's see what
could happen if they really go through
with this referendum how might it play
out well let's step back in time for a
moment
[Music]
Ferno consistent we said that nobody
really protested when Western Bob watt
fell into Indonesian hands well this
isn't exactly true as we told you
earlier Indonesia and Papua was
controlled by the Netherlands after
World War Two Indonesia became
independent and wanted to have papua as
part of their territory but the Dutch
said this made no sense think about it
there are more than 3,500 kilometers
between Jakarta and Papua they don't
have any economic historical or cultural
links so in order to solve this problem
they decided to hold a referendum the
problem well good luck trying to have
free fair and transparent elections in a
place with 1000 tribes the 1969
referendum also known erratically
perhaps as the free election act was
frankly a charade
theoretically 800,000 pop ones were
eligible to vote but only 1000 people
conveniently selected by the Indonesian
army ended up voting and they did it by
raising their hands what's more as
troops made sure that there was only one
option to choose from of course
throughout the results of the referendum
was a unanimous cried to become part of
Indonesia but I know you're thinking
back then Indonesia was under the
dictatorship of Sakana you can't expect
a dictator to organize free and fair
elections but now things are different
Indonesia is a democracy and that should
be true for Papua as well nevertheless
the problem is still the same how can
you organize elections in such a tribal
country here is where the knocking
system comes into the picture
knocking means in some Papua dialects
back basically the tribal chiefs go to
the electoral body with a bagful of
votes and they say this is what my
people vote it in some cases there isn't
even a bag the electoral body just go to
the tribal chief and ask directly so who
you go to vote for on the next elections
I don't know man like the dude in the
poster from one of the posters like the
green one dude
I asked jolly good dreams and how many
people do you have in your tribe people
300 like maybe 300 and some goats goats
people right mmm yes 300 people then
let's count the goats they're the right
ones yes good thank you sir thank you
for voting have a nice day as you can
imagine with such a well-organized
system it is no surprise that the
continent even president Joko Widodo won
a landslide victory in New Guinea by
having even more votes than voters don't
forget the goats
[Music]
pappan Electoral College finds more than
1 million people who voted twice in the
2019 elections now imagine what would
happen with this system on a
self-determination referendum it would
be easy for Papua an independent ists to
claim all the tribes voted for
self-determination also do not forget
that one third of the population
resident in Papua comes from Indonesia
and this is in fact the third of the
population that can easily be counted on
a census in other words the outcome of
this referendum would largely depend on
who gets to organise it now besides most
of the PAP ones wouldn't even care
perhaps they still don't even know that
they're considered Indonesians so this
is why we now hand the question over to
you can western papua get out of poverty
and become an independent state do you
think they can ever get past tribalism
or would it be better just to let them
be please leave your answer in the
comments section below and don't forget
to visit our friends from reconsider
media the podcast that provided the
vocals in this episode that were not
mine and if you liked this video give it
a thumbs up and as always I'll see you
next time and if you want to learn more
about politics and here even more of my
lovely voice you can join us at
reconsider media we have a podcast at
reconsider mediacom slash podcast see
you there
[Music]
you